[موسيقى]
أنت تعرف أغنية الحضانة القديمة،
نعم جيدًا، ماذا عن دب أسود واحد،
دب أسود يبلغ وزنه 450 رطلاً، يُبهج الزوار في
حديقة حيوان نوكسفيل في تينيسي،
كيف أصبح هذا البالغ من العمر 10 سنوات واسمه فين دب الفقاعات،
لقد كان نوعًا
من طاقم حراسة الحوادث السعيد  كنا
ننظف البركة باستخدام
سائل غسيل الأطباق Dawn Dawn، يعلم خبراء الحياة البرية
أنه صعب على Grease
العقلية وقد تم
استخدامه لعقود من الزمن لتنظيف
المخلوقات التي تم اصطيادها في انسكابات النفط، لذلك عندما
انتهى Keepers من تنظيف Bear Pond
وDawn المخفف أنشأ
حمامًا رغويًا.  اختار الدب أن يمرح
فيه، وقد انبهر المشاهدون
بتغريدة مجموعة حماية الدببة البريطانية التي غردت بيتي
تحب الرغوة اللاذعة في أنفه
وفي عينيه لا تحول الدب إلى
عرض غريب لكن سو نوكسفيل تقول إن
الأطباء البيطريين يزيلون جميع المنتجات التي
لا يوجد بها  لا توجد مشكلة أكثر من
أطفالك في حوض الاستحمام المليء بالفقاعات،
إنه فجر نادي حمام الدب
مع أعضاء مثل الآنسة تندرا
الرمادية في حديقة حيوان دنفر وبدون رغوة
الصابون
هذا الدب الأسود الذي يتناثر في
حديقة حيوان أوريغون يمكنك تخيله تقريبًا  فين
الدب يقول
لا تجلس في كالجون الفاخر فين
يحول نفسه من دب أسود إلى دب
قطبي
جينيموس سي إن إن
نيويورك